uh so the advice is if you wanna direct  direct and even easier if you wanna  write  right  you know i think that uh  writing is the only one of the only uh  things that can be done uh with very  little uh resources and even if you die  and you were unpublished you still have  a chance  you know it's truly you cannot do that  with directing you need other people you  need a little bit of help you need at  least an actor in front of the camera  you know but but i think these are  what i say is go and do it it's like  show us  don't tell us you know do the things and  if you do them wrong  but you're doing in your own terms  that's how i define success failing in  your own terms